the left are very effective at using a
tactic where no matter what you say if
they disagree with it they treat it as
not only wrong but the craziest damn
thing they've ever heard in their life
automatically it's the it's it's insane
it's stupid it's you know genocidal
whatever and that's actually effective
because it makes people who are kind of
on the fence or in the middle don't want
to get involved they say well okay well
if you're treating it like that then
there must be something wrong here
meanwhile when we respond to them what
they're saying actually is the craziest
damn thing we've ever heard right and
yet we lend it more legitimacy because
we sit down and say well let's uh let's
just have a civil dialogue about this
and we'll listen to your point of view
no our response should we should respond
in a way that conveys the you know the
the insanity of of what they're trying
to improve